today we're going to be one
professor in mcd be
as for molecular cellular developmental
biology so it's our biology department
so but we like to have big names at Yale
John actually he got his bachelor's
degree at another school which we often
at Yale don't like to talk about
somewhere in the Boston area but it
turns out they do produce really
brilliant people and his PhD at stanford
and now he's here at yale he even though
he looks to be about 12 years old and I
have to be honest when I first met him I
thought it was really great that they
brought in such young people to be
speaking at the thing I was speaking at
it turns out he has a full professor and
fantastic with two great kids I asked
him how he actually got interested in
science that sort of you know people
have all sorts of stories and it turned
out he wanted to be a zookeeper so you
know the obvious thing was to go into
biology and as you can see he keeps
quite an interesting zoo up here of I
believe he said it's approximately six
million fruit flies at any given time in
his laboratory which is a large number
to keep track of so with that I'd like
to welcome him he's going to be speaking
today on how fruit flies find bananas
and how mosquitoes find us so please
give him a warm welcome
well thanks Aaron for that very generous
introduction it's great to be here you
know I've actually been to most of these
science Saturday's with my kids partly
because my kids like them but mostly
because I like them so i feel very
honored to actually be giving one but
also a little bit intimidated because I
know how to rific all the previous ones
have been so we'd like to talk to you
today is about olfaction which is the
sense of smell an old faction is very
important in the animal world because
animals use of action to find food and
the locate mates and to avoid predators
and with food mates and predators all
emit are these little molecules called
odorants these are odors these are the
molecules that we actually smell alright
and different molecules different
odorants elicit very different
sensations in US and other animals a
benzaldehyde here smells like almond
this compound here smells like rose this
smells just like buttered popcorn this
is like peppermint lemon mushroom this
smells like a barnyard so a critical
question is how is it that animals
detect and identify these odors okay so
in other words how is it that these
different odors different smells are
encoded by olfactory organs like the
nose or in the case of a in case of
insects antenna how is it that these
olfactory organs produce an internal
representation inside the brain how do
they send signals to the brain and
forming the animal of which odors are
out there so most of the work I'm going
to talk to you about today it was done
in insects and this is partly because
insects just have fantastically
sensitive olfactory systems as a matter
of fact most or a lot of what we've
learned about
faction the sense of smell has been
learned from the study of insects this
one sec here its a math and believe it
or not it's that its antenna is capable
of detecting a single molecule of a
female pheromones so this is a male here
and it can pick up one molecule just
incredibly sensitive and just a few
hundred molecules are enough to make
this guy turn around and start flying
upwind in search of the female so you
can see that the antenna here are very
elaborate they're just wonderful
structures here lots of surface area to
capture and to identify these odors so
actually insect antenna come in all
different sizes and shapes and colors
they're really quite beautiful so I just
brought a few pictures of these here's
one of their feathery and here's another
one these black and white stripes you
can see here on here's a pixelated
locust with a antenna here and here's
another beautiful moth this is a
silkworm moth bombyx more I look at all
that now here's another one with nice
black and white stripes here so on one
of the nice beads on it and that cool so
when the here's one another moth and you
know I actually brought with me today
one of these mosses right in this this
thing over here along with a couple of
African butterflies so after the lecture
you can actually come up and actually
see this guy in theory of Polyphemus
alright so insecto faction is
interesting to study be partly because
these
Tenny are so beautiful but it's also a
very important real world all right
there's a couple of reasons for that
first about thirty percent thirty
percent of the world's agricultural
output is damaged every year either
directly or indirectly by insects this
is an enormous economic problem and
these are full variety of different
insects including boll weevils here ok
and this guy here infests about 10
million acres of cotton fields in the US
alone here's a grasshopper which eats
core and alpha so alpha alpha soybeans
cotton all kinds of different crops on
here's a bug which eats sorghum here's a
weevil that's about to start eating a
criminal of the grain here's before his
meal and here's after his meal so you
can see what he's done to this here's
another little beetle that's eaten flour
in storage so you can see there's just a
enormous economic problem and these are
the adults okay but also I think most of
you know that insects have a life cycle
where many of them at least lay eggs
which then hatch into larvae some more
of your cold caterpillars and in lots of
species it's these larvae to actually do
most of the damage to agriculture so
here's a worm from a moth and you can
see what it's doing to this cabbage leaf
okay and here's another one that does
tremendous devastation to corn crops
alright and then one last one is a
caterpillar that eats a lot of tomato
plants now a lot of these insects on
find their the plants that they eat the
crops that they eat on through their
sense of smell
okay so they so if basically if we can
understand better how olfaction works we
might be able to prevent them from
finding their plan toasts so this
tremendous devastation that insects do
to agriculture is one important reason
for studying insect olfaction but
there's another reason too and that's
that about a third of the world's
population is affected by diseases that
are transmitted by insects and these are
some really terrible diseases like
malaria okay which affects about 10
million ten percent of the world's
population every year there's also a
dengue fever and yellow fever African
sleeping sickness Japanese encephalitis
and now in this country we have west
nile encephalitis and again most of
these insects find us find their human
hosts primarily through their sense of
smell they smell us okay so if we can
understand the molecular and cellular
basis of how olfaction works and insects
we may be able to come up with new ways
of preventing them from finding us sort
of jamming their olfactory systems now
most of the work I'm going to talk to
you about today was done in the fruit
fly Drosophila melanogaster here's a
picture of one you can see where's when
laying an egg well it actually brought
some of these for you to show you and
don't worry they're not harmful they're
not radioactive they don't bite they're
actually quite quite elegant creatures
so if you can you pass one up and then
one of the
if you want this one
okay so why study our drosophila this
fruit fly and one reason is it has just
wonderful genetics and by that I mean
it's very easy to study its genes for
example you can take a gene out of one
of these flies and manipulate it and
then you can put it back and another fly
and see what happens to the changes
you've made how does the changes you've
made that gene affect its function also
flies have a very short generation x
it's about two weeks between a fertile
adult and then we go through an egg and
then a larva and pupa and another dealt
it only takes two weeks these guys are
very small they don't eat very much so
they're cheap and easy to keep in the
lab so they're really wonderful animals
to work with and another thing that's
nice about them is that people have been
studying them for a hundred years right
so during the course of that hundred
years it's just an enormous number of
mutants of flies that have been
identified so they're flies that have
and if you think if you look carefully
in these vials I'm passing on you can
see some fries that have curly wings
instead of normal straight wings the
flies that have kind of dark body color
instead of the normal body color and
there are flies that have if you look
very very very carefully you can see
some that have white eyes instead of red
eyes all right and one other advantage
is that they have a very small and
sequence genome and what I mean by that
is that they have only about its 120th
as much DNA and their chromosomes as we
do and we know the complete nucleotide
sequence of the agencies and GS and T's
that make up their chromosomes we know
all of that all right so so next apply
the very small and simple okay so
they've got only about a thousand
olfactory neurons of nerve cells in
their antennae whereas we have hundreds
of million so they're very easy to study
in that sense too so flies are sensitive
to just an enormous sent Norma's array
of different compounds and they sense
these through the antenna right here and
the antenna is covered with about 400
sensory hairs or sencilla as I'll call
them there's a picture of one and if you
look carefully you can see there's tiny
pores in this hair through which odors
can pass here's our little drawing here
so you can see what odor is passing
through these these holes and each one
of these hairs is got neurons or nerve
cells so we'll use those two words to be
the same a neuron is a nerve cell and is
up to four of them which cellular
processes up into this hair all right
and then here's the sort of the body of
the cell and it's going to send another
long process down into the brain okay
well it's going to terminate in a
structure here called the antennal lobe
and this looks very much like the
olfactory bulb in humans there's a lot
of very strong similarities between
olfaction in the fly in the human and
then there's more processes in the fly
brain that go up to these strange shaped
structures here called mushroom bodies
which have been implicated in olfactory
learning and memory so any of you ever
had this experience where you know you
catch a roof of a no
and all of a sudden it very vividly
reminds you of some place or some
incident at your past that ever happened
any of you like what did that happen to
you anything in comes to mind that you
sense something that reminds you
someplace very early happens to me a lot
i just kinda go into a pizza place and
smell something all the sudden it
reminds me of something before whilst
rise also a very sophisticated sense of
learning and memory okay so what I'd
like to tell you now is how we can
actually measure the response of
individual cells in the antenna to
different odors and this is how we do it
we take a fly right here and we use an
air stream to blow it up into the end of
this little plastic micropipette tip so
this little thing about this high yellow
and we push him up here so that his head
sort of lodged here wasn't any sticking
out okay and then we can put an
electrode in his antenna okay and you
know people sometimes ask you whether
this hurts the fly and I never know
quite how to answer that but well I can
tell you the end of the experiment you
can take this fly out and Pfizer and
runs all over the place he made see
seems happy so I don't think it's too
much so what this little electrode does
is a little piece of wire it goes right
into one of these sensory hairs all
right with the nerve cells that send
these processes up and so you can
measure the response of these nerve
cells okay a and B to any odor that you
put on the fly okay and let me just tell
you a little bit how that works and I
should mention that you can tell the
difference between the response of this
cell from the difference of the response
of this cell because they get electrical
signals and the electrical signal given
off by a is bigger than the electrical
signal given off by beat and I'll also
have more to say about that in just a
second so here's what we're measuring so
these are nervous impulses here's one
impulse another one another one
another one another one and these are
usually called action potentials action
potentials and sometimes they're called
spikes so all those are the same nervous
impulses action potentials and spikes
and what the ours are little changes in
the voltage across one of these nerve
cells so what happens on just very
briefly is that there's a little hole in
the cell little holes called channels
and these will open up and a some
charged ions will move through ions that
can be positively or negatively charged
and those change the voltage across the
cell so you get this little change in
voltage oh that's what we're measuring
here okay but it's very quick it only
lasts a few milliseconds that's why this
is so short so this is the time scale
here so it's just a little blip another
book another blip so these nerve cells
fire these action potentials
spontaneously all right and here's on
the nerve cell that just follows a few
low frequency here's one that
spontaneously fires more and the last
thing I need to tell you about these
these action potentials or spikes as
they move down the nerve on they move
move down all the way into the brain so
they're sending information from the
antenna into the brain that's what they
do so that's sort of how that the brain
figures out what's going out there going
on out in the outside world is because
of these action potentials that move
down these nerve cells into the brain
okay so here are some spores spontaneous
action potentials but now they're
happens if we give a whiff of over
here's just a half second pulse of ethyl
acetate which smells kind of fruity well
you can see is that we get this big
burst of action potentials here alright
it's a train of these things that goes
very quickly and if you look carefully
there are the big action potentials they
all come from we call that a cell the
one that makes the big action potentials
the B cell that makes the little action
potentials I've mark that with dots and
you can see that doesn't respond to this
odor so in other words if you give
impulsive ethyl acetate then the a sale
starts firing like crazy the frequency
of these signals goes up by contrast on
in this same since ilum remember there's
an a cell and obese on the same since
Silla if you give a pulse a four-level
phenol which smells like a barnyard it's
the B cell that responds like crazy okay
so we have two cells in the same rule
hair and one of them is sensitive to
this fruity odor and the other sensitive
to the barnyard odor okay and I just had
to be fun just to bring some real data
that you can actually hear because what
we can do is we can hook up not only do
we see these patterns on an oscilloscope
on this little TV screen but in addition
to that we can hook it up to a
loudspeaker which will actually register
each one of these action potentials now
remember there's two kinds there's the a
action potentials which are b-side the a
ones which come from this ace other big
and then there's the B ones coming from
the B cell which are small and what
you're going to hear is two kinds of
sound on this there's the sort of a
high-pitched sound from this a cell and
a low pitch sound coming from the B cell
so this first recording i'm going to
show you is just from a spontaneous
neuron there's no odors around and this
is what it sounds like
hi
okay so that pop sort of staticky sound
that's the a cell and then if you could
hear this rumbling noise at the bottom
was the B cell now let's give it the
whiff of the barnyard takes a little bit
trick to get started and then what
you're going to hear is this be so that
they are the real deep one is going to
start going very quickly so you're going
to be a lot of these action potentials
so it's going to make a lot of noise so
listen to this takes a little
yeah it's aaron stomach to herd right
but it's also a barnyard that the b-cell
hurt okay so what you can do then is you
can systematically measure the responses
of these cells to a whole panel of
different odors so we've just picked a
motors here various different kinds of
odors and we've asked how strong it is
each neuron or nerve cell respond and
we're just counting the number of these
action potentials per second or spikes
per second so this fish salad looked at
respond strongly to ethyl acetate this
fruity odor but also gives a response to
another 23 butanediol and some very weak
responses to some other odors now here's
a letter cell which responds a very
strongly to journal acetate which is the
odor of rose okay very nice floral scent
but it doesn't respond to anything at
all anything other than rose okay so
we've got two different nerve cells
which respond to different subsets of
odors okay so in other words different
nerve cells will probe report the
existence of different folders that are
out in the environment so this raises a
very important question in olfaction and
an olfactory system like ours or flies
how many different types of these nerve
cells are there and how narrow or broad
are their specificities you know one
extreme you can imagine that a fly might
have a thousand different types of nerve
cells each responding to one specific
odor or the other extreme you can
imagine that might be very small number
of nerve cells each responding to lots
of odor so which is it so a dutch
postdoc came to our lab and he picked a
panel of 50 different odors and he
tested a lot of high concentrations and
he test
on all the nerve cells he could find in
the antenna and he found that he could
identify sixteen different classes of
nerve cells each one indicated by a
vertical column here alright and so
we're 750 entries in this table and what
he found was that about eighty-five
percent of them were zeros only fifteen
percent of them actually gave an
appreciable response so and that's even
testing these orders of very high
concentration so what that tells you is
that most of these nerve cells respond
to only a small fraction of odors
they're quite selective and what they
respond to I've marked the best over for
each neuron in yellow and you can see
they're pretty much different for each
neuron type alright and the last thing I
just want to pull out if so is one
neuron here that didn't respond to any
order we tried we couldn't figure out
why that was and then finally marine
this post doc had this great idea and he
tried carbon dioxide the thing when
firing like crazy is a screaming
response and that was kind of
interesting because there are insects
like mosquitoes and sexy flies they
actually use carbon dioxide to find us
their human hosts so for these flies in
help us carbon dioxide sensitive cell as
well now how are these different cells
actually organized on the antenna well
they're organized in these sensory hairs
as you can see here there's one kind of
sensory here that's got four of them and
the others all have two and their
combined in a very stereotyped way that
you're very according to a very strict
pairing rule you always find one of
these neural cells and the right next to
one of these you always find one of
these nerve cells right next one of
those and how are they actually
distributed on the surface of the
antenna well again there's a lot of
order to this this is the front half of
the antenna this is the back half of the
antenna and
that individual types are restricted to
particular regions of the antenna like
the number 3s are all up top here and
the number 7s are down here so there's
everything like different types but each
type as a characteristic distribution on
the surface of the antenna okay so this
is what I wanted to tell you about the
cellular basis how cells mediate
olfaction the cellular basis of
olfaction okay and I've shown you
there's different kinds of cells in the
antenna the different kinds of cells
respond to different groups of odors and
I've shown you that the neurons these
nerve cells that respond to odors are
combined in these sensory hairs decent
so in a very particular way and that
different since Ilyn and different
neurons are distributed in different
parts of the antenna so that's the
cellular basis of olfaction I want to
talk about now let me tell you about the
molecular basis of olfaction how does
this all work in terms of molecules okay
so in order to get at that we
desperately needed to identify the
receptors for odors that is the protein
molecules that sit in the surfaces of
these nerve cells and actually grab out
and grab hold and bind to these odors
okay so what are these receptors well it
turns out and I should mention these
receptors are the ones which after they
bind their odor they send a little
signal to the cell which causes this
nerve cell to fire so the binding of a
receptor to an odor is what actually
makes one of these nerve cells fire okay
so it turns out that there are 60
different genes in the chromosomes of
the fly which make these odor receptors
okay and they're scattered over the X
chromosome the second chromosome and the
third chromosome 60 of these genes each
one of these little arrows as a gene
and each one makes a receptor which can
bind to an odor all right so now it
turns out an important question to ask
here is which cells is are going to make
which receptors okay and it's on there's
a beautiful way of asking this question
it says some technology that originally
was developed right here at Yale in the
Klein biology tower by a wonderful
professor named Joe call a number of
years ago and I'm not going to go over
the details of it but basically what
allows you to do is it you can stain
with a nice color all the cells that are
making a particular receptor so this is
odor receptor 47a and the cells that
make that receptor all get turned purple
according to this series of chemical
reactions that you do the point I want
to make here is that different receptors
like the soda receptor 22b are made by
different subsets of size so these are
different cells from these all right so
each receptor is made by a different
subset of cells and different receptors
are made by different subsets so now the
interesting point is that these patterns
of cells that we've determined through
sort of molecular biology looking at
molecules is there a reminiscent of the
patterns of cells that we saw through
all these functional tests we did we're
actually measuring electrophysiological
it's sticking an electrode in and seeing
which neurons respond to which odors and
so that raised the question is what sort
of correspondence is there between these
receptors and these cells all right so
in other words which receptors are made
by which cells and to do that we've done
a project that I want to tell you about
which is a whole lot of fun I have to
say in which we mapped odors to
receptors and receptors to neurons okay
so basically what
figuring out which on odors are
stimulate which receptors which do they
bind to in which two they activate and
which of these receptors are made by
which of these cells so we're trying to
get to understand how this system is all
put together at the molecular and
cellular level to do this we used a
mutant a mutant of yourself remember I
said one of the great things about your
safa was it has fantastic genetics and
all these mutants out there well we used
a mutant which had a little deletion in
one of its chromosomes the second
chromosome is a tiny little deletion
that means it's just missing part of its
chromosome and what it's missing
includes this odor receptor 22 a gene so
it's missing one of these odor receptors
and we noticed that in this mutant that
was lacking 102 receptor one particular
one of these nerve cells a nerve cell
that normally responds to ethel butyrate
that nerve sal loses response to
everything so if you take away this
receptor this cell can no longer respond
to anything and we call this this neuron
here this mutant are on the empty neuron
now of course it's not really empty it's
got plenty of stuff in it but it's
missing its receptor so we call it the
empty neuron which turns out to be very
convenient and what you can do okay so
here's a normal neuron that which
normally expresses the 22 a receptor and
response to ethel butyrate in this
mutant we have on you lose that receptor
and you lose response to all odors well
it turns out through genetic engineering
some some actually fairly
straightforward stuff you can get this
neuron to make another receptor orx so
you basically substituted orx for 22 a
and then you can ask when you put in
this other receptor what is this
I'll do what odors does it respond to it
kind of responding to fo butyrate does
it respond to something different and
you can do that by sticking one of these
electrodes inside and actually asking
which odor will get this neuron to fire
to make responses okay so here's our
empty neuron that doesn't respond to
anything at all and then we put in this
photo receptor 7a and what happens is
now all of a sudden we get a strong
response to e2 xml and that smells just
like graphs you know the grass in July
when you're running across the graph
that's what ito hexanol smells like so
this receptor then seems like it's a
receptor for this grass odor and
interestingly this pattern here of
responses you're a little bit weaker
response to one hex and also we're
measuring the number of spikes per
second another electrical activity we
get when we give each of these odors and
this overall pattern will very much like
the pattern we saw with one of these on
the nerve cells we characterized in the
normal animal than normal fly so the
simplest interpretation of our less than
is that this receptor responds to e to
hex and l and that this nerve cell
normally expresses this receptor makes
that receptor okay let me show you
another example here's when we put this
59b receptor in this empty neuron we now
get a strong response to ethyl acetate
at the 23 die butanone and a pattern
looks very much like this nerve cell
here when we put the 10 a receptor we
got a very strong response to
wintergreen that smells just like the
little lifesavers those winter green I
slavers so 10 a is a receptor for
wintergreen lifesavers and that looks
very much like on this pattern and
finally when we put the 80 to risk a
receptor in we get a strong response to
the odor of rose this looks like a rose
receptor and it's a pattern it looks
very much like that of this narrow
so we got this to work for for most of
the receptors not all of them but most
of them and from all the data put it all
together we could make a receptor tuner
on map of the fly antennae so we figured
out and we filled in this map later but
anyway now we know which receptors are
made by which cells so this approach
also asked us allowed us to ask a very
important question about how odors are
identified across all the receptor all
the nerve cells of a whole olfactory
system okay so how is it did you
actually figure out that there's been an
over there an apple over there well on
what we did was we took on all the
receptors and this is work done by
fantastic graduate student named Alyssa
Hallam who systematically tested all
these receptors in this empty neuron
system this is a whole lot of work and
she tested all of them against this
panel of diverse odors all right what
she found was that there were some
receptors that responded to lots of the
odors so they were total broadly tuned
they're responding to lots of different
things and other receptors are spotted
only to one or none so they look like
they're more narrow
to the more picky more specific and what
they're going to respond to and if you
look at this from the point of view of
the older okay there are some odors that
activated lots of receptors and some
that activated only one so the bottom
line remodel is a take-home message then
is that different odors will activate
different subsets of receptors different
groups of receptors and remember each
one of these receptors is in a different
nerve cell so in other words each odor
will will activate different orders will
activate different subsets of these
nerve cells so the brain gets different
information according to which odors out
there the brain can identify an odor
based on which subset of these receptors
are being activated okay now I know you
guys come in a whole distribution there
young people here are older people and
so I want to just spend two minutes
telling you something that is for sort
of more the high school students and
then I'll come back and Evans will only
take a couple minutes another way of
sort of showing all this kind of data is
to UM can create what we call an odor
space all right so what I've done here
is I've drawn a three dimensional graph
where the x-axis here represents the
response of just one receptor in spikes
per second the 47 a receptor the wire
axis represents the response of the 85b
receptor and the z axis represents the
response of the 10 a receptor in which
you can do is you can plot in this space
each odor so here to hep danone and
pencil acetate actually map very close
together in this three-dimensional space
constructed for 3 receptors and methyl
salicylate maps away
far away all right now this is just 3
receptors a three-dimensional space so
how about if you make a space
constructed out of other responses of
all the receptors all 24 but it's kind
of hard to see a 24 dimensional space
that can't draw that very well but
there's some some math you can do to
take a twenty four dimensional space and
kind of Rutgers that into three
dimensions and when you do that this is
what you get you find it again pentel
acetate and a2 Hepton own okay map very
very close together and methyl
salicylate maps far apart so this raises
an interesting question basically what
we're saying sort of that the bottom
line of all this is that pentyl acetate
and to have to note are very similar in
terms of the patterns of receptor
activity that they elicit across the
whole repertoire of receptors so does
that mean that supply to the flower to
have to known and myths of ethyl acetate
smell very very similar and that methyl
salicylate smells very different all
right well so we're actually testing
that in the lab now but but i find this
kind of provocative because to me
personally to Hepton own and pentyl
acetates know very similar
whereas methyl salicylate smells very
different okay and this morning when
you're coming in I'm personally I kind
of wanted to know you know I'd like to
know whether other people feel that way
as well so I put out vials a labeled a B
and C and I guess a bunch of you
actually smelled a B and C and I asked
Aaron to sort of take note whether most
people thought one of these odors
smelled different from the other two and
so until she was tell me which one which
other people thought smells different
from the other two there it has a flair
for drama as you can tell okay and the
older the people thought was different
on was a and a was methyl salicylate a
good job guys
which color was a don't remember green
green ok so did that smell different to
you good all right good.you know I have
to say I did this test once and a bunch
of Yale faculty member who are older and
you know someone were kind of going down
well can you erase that from the
videotape but anyway and enrich I have
to say they'll virtually every but
although the deal professors thought
that this odor smelled very different
but the interesting thing is that
there's this guy Andy Hamilton who's a
chemistry professor now who is now our
Provost the University for the Yale
University Provost so he raised his hand
and said John you know to be smelled a
lot to me like two Hepton own is that
right and you know I couldn't tell to me
they smell the same thing but I I've
lived through all my notes and found out
that shirt off the guy was right and so
my conclusion from that is that that's
why he's the University Provost and
they're just ordinary faculty members
okay so all of this is a way of
identifying the item odor quality what
kind of an odor is out there but it's
also very important for an animal to be
able to evaluate odor quantity how much
of an odor is out there and that's
important because as an animal as an
insect is flying towards a food source
or towards a mate on it has to know
whether the odors becoming stronger or
weaker so how does it do that okay and
you know this is a problem for us too
i'm sure you have this this those things
happen where you catch a whiff of an
odor and you're trying to figure out
where it's coming from it can be very
perplexing so in fact i saw this here
tell mrs. pommeroy we found the source
of that strange hint of musk so here's
how insects do it we think so we do is
we systematically tested all these odors
against all the receptors initially a
very high concentration and we found
that most of these odors are listed at a
moderate or strong response from most of
the receptors ok so this kiss of a
profile looks very much like New York
City looks like the Manhattan skyline
right if you dilute the amount of odor
try 100 fold ok you now get a sparser
representation there are fewer strong
responses fewer odors elicit strong
responses and the responses tend to be
weaker so you get a profile that looks
like Philadelphia if you then go down
another two orders of magnitude to add
another hundred fold you get even a
sparser representation that looks more
like Hartford and if you go down still
another 100 fold you get Ames Iowa which
is actually the town that I would
brought up then so the basic take home
message from this end is we think that
an animal can distinguish how much of an
odor is out there based on how many
strong responses it is it gets across
all these receptors and how strong those
responses are all right now I want to
move on to the last part of my talk here
I mentioned earlier that insect
olfaction is tremendously important in
the real world in part because hundreds
of millions of people every year suffer
these miserable infections that they get
from that are transmitted by by insects
which find us through the sense of smell
and one of the worst of these is malaria
okay there's 500 million cases of
malaria a year and it's transmitted by
this mosquito here anopheles gambiae a
which has been called the most danger
animal in the world so here's the
mosquito it's just landed on someone and
here's this is before he's eat it he she
she it's the females that actually on
bite and take egg take a blood from us
for their they needed to nourish their
eggs so here's before the meal and
here's after the meal okay actually a
little warming different part of my talk
here okay so what happens well though
female when she bites us she actually
delivers some of this little piece
little parasites which move into liver
cells okay and then they come out of the
liver cells and then infected blood
cells alright and then they come out of
the blood cells and then if another
mosquito comes and bites us that she
will take up some of these parasites ok
and then delivered it to another person
so that's how the disease is transmitted
from one person to another but the
bottom line that's the essential step is
that the female mosquito has to smell us
and find us okay and just to underline
the importance of this is over
deaths worldwide each year it's just a
terrible terrible disease ok and the
mosquito has an olfactory system here's
the antenna covered with sensor and it
turns out of this mosquito has 79
different odor receptors all right well
this empty their own system i told you
about works so well with looking at the
receptors of the fruit fly we thought we
will just give it a try and see whether
it might work with an odor receptor from
a mosquito so remember here's our empty
neuron which basically doesn't respond
to any of these odors we tried when we
put in a very first photo receptor from
the mosquito that we identified called a
Geo r14 anopheles gambiae a 02 receptor
1 and we try to hold that your chemicals
and nothing happened in this empty
neuron system okay but then my grad
student Melissa pulled a few more
chemicals off the shelf and one of them
floor methyl phenyl obviously this
screaming response one of the strongest
responses we've ever seen to any odor ND
receptor and that was interesting
because are they really know at the time
we found out that this is actually a
composite of human sweat okay and even
more provocative is that this receptor
here is a female specific receptor it's
only the females that make this receptor
the male's don't make it and it's only
the females that navigate towards humans
and bite us okay so that raised the
possibility that this could be part at
least the system that the mosquito uses
to actually find the human host that she
be that she lands on and turn to room
she transmits malaria alright so we've
been
recently then is to systematically go
through that we're systematically going
through all 79 of these odor receptors
from the mosquito and so far every
single one of them has worked with one
exception and when I say worked we've
been able to find compounds that either
excite these receptors or inhibit them
and that's interesting because it's
possible that some of these compounds
that excite these receptors could be
useful in developing new mosquito traps
if you mix together some compounds of
very very potent ly attract mosquitoes
this could be useful to make some new
mosquito traps on and also compounds
that inhibit these receptors could be
useful in designing new mosquito
repellents all right so what we're doing
now is we actually a nice collaboration
with five groups and compounds that we
identify here at Yale that is activate
or inhibit these receptors are then
tested in a lab in Holland which is very
good at measuring the response of
mosquitoes in a wind tunnel so asks
whether they actually attract them or
repel them in a lab and compounds that
look useful there are then tested down
in Tanzania and East Africa where we
have some collaborators who can test the
flight of mosquitoes in a more natural
situation out in the savanna and then on
compounds that work interesting where
are then tested in The Gambia and
the village which has Hut's where you
can set up so you can measure on the
rate at which mosquitoes fly in and out
of huts so I can think of a whole bunch
of reasons why this may possibly not
actually work but the way I told myself
is that with a disease that affects 500
million people a year if we can come up
with something that will just reduce the
incidence by 0.1 percent there'll be
500,000 people that were helping so I
figure it's worth trying all right so
just to summarize that I've told you
today I told you would give you an
introduction to olfaction and showed you
how we could find which odors on
activate which receptors which receptors
are located in which nerve cells which
give us a receptor tuner on map of the
floral factory system I showed you the
different odors indicated by these
different dots here elicit different
patterns of activity among all the
receptors taken together and that this
could be used by the animal to identify
odor quality which odors out there and
it could possibly also be useful and
seem making a predictions about which
odors are easy for an animal to
discriminate orders are very close may
be hard to discriminate I also showed
you the lower concentrations of odors
elicited a sparsely representation in
among the receptor repertoire which
provides a means of identifying odor
quantity and last I showed you that
mosquitoes or mosquito receptors can
actually function in a fly and that we
use this to identify a female specific
receptor that responds to a component of
human sweat so where is always kind of
word get done what sort of situations
this happening well they say we're go
talk to you about today we've actually
done right
here unclimbed biology tower which
you're familiar right up here on the
11th floor and the kind of people who
actually done these experiments are
wonderful people who came to Yale from
all over the world marine Des Moines
came from Holland and the most of the
work on the cellular basis of odor
coating that is we measured all those
different neurons and figure out which
they responded to Peter Klein who came
from New York but actually grew up in
India and coral war came from Australia
they work together to actually find
these other receptors and insects a lot
of work and science gets done through
collaboration there's something that we
know how to do but or something we don't
know how to do but you have a friend at
a different University knows how to do
it so you get together and you send a
lot of emails and get together and talk
over the phone and together there's a
synergy and you can do things that
needle up could do by itself Jim Yong
Kim has been a wonderful collaborator
who helped her off with some critical
parts of this study argue the roots of
graduate student who came to us from
Russia just south of moscow and another
dutch pro stock we know amanda boost or
notice a pioneered this empty neuron
system but most of the work on the empty
neuron system in the first or softer
work first we're kind of CEOs was done
by fantastic grad student named alyssa
how i'm working from california and
other parts of the story that haven't
talked about today we're done by people
from all over
from other parts of the world so I just
wanted to say thank you for your
attention and I'm happy to answer any
questions you might have
I think the main effect of quinine is on
the parasite itself there's been a very
interesting study recently showing that
this is published a few months ago it's
related to that which your question
releases and out is that there's
evidence that people who are infected
with malaria are more attractive to
mosquitoes and that kind of makes sense
because on for the parasites point of
view if it wants to propagate itself it
would be a good idea to make something
which is going to attract a mosquito
which will then carry it to another
person that it can grow in and then keep
going so it's turned out to be very
interesting this relationship between
the on attraction to the mosquito and
the parasite itself very fruity odor
yeah it's hard little hard to pinpoint a
particular fruit but you smell and you
think of that yeah I'm sopping so
acetate that's a little bit different
and feel food there's actually 002 but
that's on see-tube see so take a whiff
of it on your way out yeah and by the
way I brought a whole bunch of cool
insects here these are some some nervous
butterflies and moss from all over the
rules and tropics and stuff and some
huge rhinoceros beetles they're also
some really cool ones in here that you
can take a look at and I brought some
other species so various insects here
that are alive and this is a terrific
rhinoceros beetle from Malaysia and
there's some live moths and butterflies
from Africa over there
strange things happening to peace a lot
of bees disappeared and if it's relate
something to like manipulation you get a
bigger manipulation for the plans or if
you can tell us something about you know
what's happening yeah I think there's
been a more interesting this has been a
parasite that's been infecting a lot of
bees and that's big problem because we
depend on bees to pollinate crops and so
if the bee population goes into a
tailspin we're in big trouble and the
bee olfactory system is really terrific
I debts got on it's even more
sophisticated I think than the fly
olfactory system it's got on a lot of
receptors and all the places the brain
for them to wire to and the bees are
capable of learning all kinds of odors
very well so it's a remarkable factory
system and a species that's got a lot of
importance for the real world yeah yeah
they're trying to train the beasts yeah
everyone's all get a call from someplace
like DARPA you know the defense people
who want to see if we can train bees to
Detective no terrorists and also mines
mines land mines because there's an
unreadable number of landmines buried
all over the world and that's a real
problem so there's interest in sort of
seen whether you can get insects to have
these terrific senses of smell to
actually find where the land mines are
are buried then you could deactivate
them and also to use in airports you
know for fine so there has been a lot of
interest in these DARPA people show up
every once in a while I want to talk
about that yeah yes yeah yep please
yeah that's a good question I think they
they have good for a process called
diapause where they sort of shut down
it's kind of like hibernation and sun
but you know it's amazing how little we
know about that you know there's
thousands of people who study these
insects and labs and I think that's a
great question that yeah yeah there's
very very little information about when
i first got was feel I kept asking that
to always ask about fruit flies you know
what all the fruit flies go when nobody
can give me a good answer this where we
hang out in their garbage cans are so
good because 2300 and I I don't know how
many of them make it but some of them
definitely do and the way they do it is
they sort of shut down and go into this
hibernation mode where I think they make
these anti freeze proteins in their
their blood to help them make it through
the winter but but we know vanishing
lead a little about that I think it's a
really exciting topic for future
research yeah yeah please yes
does any of this any of these findings
have applications to repeal has from
props yes absolutely on and there's a
couple ways of doing that on Asha I
think attractants are probably the best
way to use in agriculture and and it
actually they already have been used
successfully in some cases where you can
on put a whole lot of an attractant in a
field and so that the insects that are
in the area it's a very potent
attractant will go in and get trapped in
that attractant so there's actually been
a lot of interests take do they do is
they actually have sometimes really
called big crops they'll have one row of
crops that's got something very
attractive they just sacrifice that they
let the animals eat that in the hopes of
sparing all the other rows of crops yeah
but this is big business man I mean
there's just you know billion-dollar
agricultural industry when you showed
you all these pictures of these insects
just trashing these things so there's
real opportunities here for it for using
what we've learned about molecular and
cellular biology to come up with new
ways of approaching these problems